this episode is sponsored by
nordvpn dear lady eage I formally invite
your attendance a new Theory Mr fingers
it's been so long but we have a new
Theory I must ask that you hush pipe
down
Sunshine theorize
faster
yes
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show where salad is back on the menu
hey does anyone remember Salad Fingers
this is one of the classics of Internet
horror created by David fth 20 years ago
for the OG animation website Newgrounds
before it migrated over here to
youtube.com no joke I first heard about
this thing back in high school when kids
were daring each other to go and watch
it you know what it's been going strong
ever since releasing a new episode once
every few years to terrify a brand new
generation of viewer what say you about
it Lee yeah I love horror Cinema and it
takes a lot to unnerve me but Salad
Fingers has to be one of the most
off-putting things I've ever watched in
a good way that's clearly what the
Creator intended and it just gives me
the ick it's the art style right yeah
that and the mouth sounds we best get
you in training squirty box for me it's
all the squelching
noises
but not only does Mr fingers have a soft
spot in my heart as a series that's
grown up alongside me it's also just one
of my favorite Mysteries that we've ever
covered on the channel since the
beginning the fragmented mind of Salad
Fingers has been endlessly fascinating
to pick at kind of like a festering scab
erupting with black pus why is this
world a desert Wasteland what are the
real identities of salad's Puppet Pals
and why are we rubbing so much rusted
Cutlery despite the Creator saying that
they were going to trash all the
theories then saying that I was wrong
then saying it was all meaningless and
made up in a drug fueled binge and then
ultimately saying last year that I was
doing a good job before ultimately going
off the rails like I tend to this is
just one of those stories that sticks in
your head by virtue of how unique it is
that's why when we were discussing ideas
for my final 10 theories on the channel
I knew we had to come back to the
Wasteland one final time in case you
missed or forgot our older Salad Fingers
theories which despite them being 7
years old at this point they hold up so
well got to be honest I had also
forgotten a lot of the things that we
said in them and man it was a joy to go
revisit those editing was on point
anyway here are the bullet points that
you need to know in order to understand
today's theory on the surface Salad
Fingers is just a creepy series about a
green mutant thing flirting with dead
animal corpses birthing black blobs and
just a whole lot of cannibalism a whole
lot of cannibalism but pretty quickly it
becomes clear that there is more under
the surface here strange dialogue
references to Real World locations and
events even the use of repeated themes
show us that there's more substance
buried under the surface of this leafy
green dish and when you start to piece
together the clues you learn that what
we're really witnessing here is the
fractured psyche of an Eng Englishman in
a post World War I Britain specifically
the year 1939 Salad Fingers is trapped
in a sort of Arrested Development
struggling with the slew of mental
disorders caused by a life of Parental
abuse and grief from losing his brother
a lot of these issues manifest in the
form of dissociative identity disorder
with Salad Fingers slipping between
various personalities and personas
including several finger puppet
representations of real people from his
earlier life first we've got Hubert
cumberdale salad fingers's core
personality representative of his desire
to become a real boy worthy of a
acceptance ladies and gentlemen a new
improved a Huber comale I've suspected
for a while now that Hubert cumberdale
was Salad Fingers before he became Salad
Fingers this is actually further
supported in the new episodes that we're
going to be talking about today notice
the hair on Hubert cumberdale and now
the hair on salad as he dresses up for
his date is practically the same why
must you keep so many Secrets Mr fingers
I'll pretend you didn't say that even
here we see him turn a mirror onto
Hubert only to reflect back his own
image you'll never be a real boy Hubert
cumberdale other finger puppet
personalities include Jeremy fiser based
on salad fingers's biological father and
also Marjorie Stewart Baxter a
representation of a female presence in
salad fingers's life it's not entirely
made clear who she is but I suspect that
it's his wife throughout the series it
becomes clear that salad fingers didn't
have the best relationship with the rest
of his family from everything we can
tell he was born out of wedlock to a
mixed race couple the of a romantic
trist held during the war this
immediately makes him ostracized in the
family being seen as unclean scrub that
muck off at once Huber comale I'll have
no dirty immigrants in my house it also
becomes clear thanks to the frequent
mentions of the Beast that he was raised
in an extremely religious household why
is
gler so mean he he was raised under the
Beast son so the fact that he's an
illegitimate child just makes him more
of a Target throughout the series we see
him slip into the persona of angry
father figures abusive mother figures
taunting siblings you're a stupid boy
yes mother I am a stupid by that's
largely where we left things 5 years ago
however since we last chatted about
Salad Fingers all the way back in 2019 F
has released two brand new episodes of
the series hostman and harvest not only
did these two uploads give us more
detail about salad's Origins and broken
family but shockingly it also shows us
the death of salad fingers so what's it
all mean well don't get all billias on
me friends grab a rusty kettle and let's
go so I think the best way to start here
is by breaking down exactly what happens
in each of the two new episodes starting
with number 12 Postman this episode
follows Salad Fingers as he plays the
role of a postal service worker
delivering mail to various imaginary
folks around the Wasteland however
things change when salad meets a new
hire at the Postal Service a young girl
represented by the half decayed carcass
of a dog but there's a bit of a problem
Salad Fingers quickly becomes infatuated
with this girl despite the fact that she
seems much younger than he is they must
be hiring new staff certainly younger
than the usual after sharing several
romantic moments together at least as
romantic as you can get with the Rotting
Flesh of a dead animal salad is
confronted by the girl's father a dog
baby hybrid that looks like it's a
failed Full Metal Alchemist experiment
the father starts dragging the daughter
away as salad fingers laments that the
relationship was never going to work out
I was a fool to think she'd be the next
Mrs fingers so what's going on here well
this episode isn't about salad fingers
it's actually about his father Jeremy
fiser it's all about how Salad Fingers
imagines Hubert cumberdale conception
how do we know this well throughout the
episode there's a lot of suggestive
imagery for example at the end of the
postman's date he takes the girl to a
secluded area where he suggestively
pokes her with a stick obvious symbolism
is obvious but just to make sure that
you really get it he then plucks and
eats a nearby flower in this case he is
metaphorically deflowering this girl dog
thing what's more the entire
interference of an ominous Father Figure
in a romance isn't the first one that
we've seen in the series in episode 6
present there are a pair of seemingly
disconnected dialogue sequences where
Salad Fingers has a one-sided
conversation with himself spce them
together and you get this Jeremy Fisher
I thought you were out fighting the
Great War I'm not one for accusations
but this one's cast iron I've seen you
tailgating my daughter with aspirations
of deflowering her Rose it's an exchange
between Jeremy fiser and the
intimidating father of a girl that
Jeremy's accused of attempting to to
deflower there's that word again the
story of Postman then this date between
Jeremy fiser and a younger girl is
exactly what the angry father from
episode 6 was referring to but that's
just a bit of extra context for a story
that we largely knew the broad Strokes
of episode 13 meanwhile well this is
where we encounter something entirely
different episode 13 Harvest is all
about exactly that Salad Finger prepping
for a harvest but lamenting that he
doesn't have enough food for everyone
due to the poultry crop this year this
year's Grand Feast is certain to be a
disaster notably we also see Salad
Finger slipping back into the role of
Hubert cumberdale parents let's just say
his home wasn't exactly the most loving
place it's here where we get the sense
that Hubert's mother was all about
striving to achieve a higher social
class that's why this Harvest dinner
that they're preparing is so crucial
well beating guests from the higher
Society this is our chance to ascend
hoping to help the situation Salad
Finger sacrifices an old finger puppet
burying it in the ground what's
especially interesting is that this
puppet named Melvin wish cake is someone
brand new to the series but wasn't meant
to be after doing some digging we were
able to learn via a 2021 tweet that
Melvin was actually an unused character
originally planned to appear all the way
back in episode 2 we also know based on
this document that he was intended to be
unemployed just a fun little side note
there by burying him in the ground Mr
fingers is able to summon a supernatural
being known as grandmother growth she
feeds in Vines and then offers up an
eyeball for Salad Fingers to eat an
eyeball that eventually causes the
growth to appear on salad fingers's back
this eventually spawns into a brand new
character mini finger fingers hello Mr
fingers hello miniature Mr fingers Salad
Fingers quickly takes this new offshoot
known as boy fingers under his wing
teaching him about the area they live in
and training him to do various medial
tasks that they prepare for the grand
Feast however as Salad Fingers is
speaking to his finger puppets and
encouraging them to embrace boy fingers
as part of the family boy finger sneaks
up behind him and hits him in the head
with a large Rock when Salad Fingers
regains Consciousness he realizes that
boy fingers is turning him into a stew
before he dies salad tries to pass on
some last bits of knowledge to boy
fingers but is largely dismissed it's
all taken care of I do most apologize
it's all in your hands now and with
Salad Fingers truly cooked boy fingers
serves them up for the greatest of
Feasts only for no one to arrive so he
just begins to eat salad fingers himself
now this is a weird episode which you
know is saying a lot considering the
series that we're talking about here but
for as esoteric and disconnected as
harvest first appears it's actually
continuing a recurring theme that's been
happening throughout most other episodes
Parenthood as as we've pointed out in
previous theories a lot of salad
fingers' narrative grapples with what it
means to have children and practically
every time Salad Fingers is afraid of
that responsibility and ultimately runs
away he leaves the embryo shaped Stitch
head brokenhearted in episode 4 he
decides to give his daughter Avana away
in episode 9 after also walking away
from the infant like Mr branches earlier
that same episode but here we get
something different this time Salad
Fingers stays when boy fingers emerges
from his back salad doesn't run away or
abandon him instead he does his best to
raise him which while a noble gesture is
also the thing that eventually gets him
killed but before we continue unraveling
the mystery of Salad Fingers let's talk
about another terrifying topic cyber
security and how you can keep yourself
safe online with the sponsor of today's
episode nordvpn if you somehow don't
have a VPN yet we really need to have
this conversation when you're browsing
the web so much of your private
information's at risk any hacker
motivated enough can easily get a hold
of that information and use it for
whatever nefarious purpose they want but
with a VPN like Nord Just Like Salad
Finger slipping through his different
personas you can protect your private
information from any bad guys wanting to
get a hold of it when browsing with a
VPN it's harder for them to even know
who you are let alone grab anything
harmful so your internet data stays safe
behind nord's encryption plus nordvpn
has a strict no logs policy and masks
your IP address that means that they
don't collect your private data and that
no one can track what you're doing on
the internet because your business is
none of their business whatever you're
doing online is between you and your
finger puppets and no one else but
nordvpn can do so much more than just
hide your internet activity it can also
make websites think that your internet
connection's coming from somewhere else
even from an entirely different country
we're actually using nordvpn for this
exact purpose right now believe it or
not we have to watch a lot of content
for film Theory and it sucks that all
the movies and TV shows are split up
amongst the streamers I'm re-watching
Rick and Morty right now for another
upcoming Theory and I'm annoyed cuz it
isn't available on Netflix here in the
States but it is over on the UK version
of Netflix so I just open up Nord click
one of their British servers and all of
a sudden I'm hunting down Rick Prime
without need needing to sign up for a
brand new streamer all in all vpn's are
essential if you want to keep yourself
safe online these days and there's no
better choice right now than Nord it
works on basically any device whether
it's your phone PC laptop or tablet and
you can connect up to six devices at
once and best of all if you use my link
right now you're going to get an insane
deal on a 2-year plan with Nord even
throwing in an extra 4 months for free
yeah you heard that one right so if you
want to start protecting yourself right
now and see everything that a VPN has to
offer go check out nordvpn.com film the
for a huge discount on a 2-year plan
plus four additional months for free
plus it's all risk-free with a 30-day
money back guarantee all by going to my
Link at nordvpn.com fi l m t h e o r y
or you know just click the link down in
the description below thanks again to
nordvpn for sponsoring this portion of
the video and now let's Scuttle on back
over to that fascinating and creepy
world of salad fingers so Salad Fingers
gives birth to this new boy but unlike
him abandoning childlike figures in the
past this time he stays and this
continues a theme that we've seen in the
latter episodes of the series in episode
11 we see him rejoice in making Hubert
into a real boy even fighting off his
family to protect him and again here
with boy fingers we see him making a
real attempt to raise this child while
he's firm he's not violent or demanding
like the other father figures that we've
seen throughout the series even when boy
fingers is preparing the Salad Finger
stew Salad Fingers doesn't once say
anything negative despite being cooked
alive instead his concern is all about
continuing to pass on knowledge to the
Next Generation I'll need to show you
where we keep the spare towels and of
course hbert swollen ankle requires
ointment he's trying to approach raising
boy fingers with a New Perspective a new
point of view in short earlier episode
showed us Salad Fingers playing out the
reaction Hubert's mother had to her son
disowning him abandoning him telling him
to toughen up saying that he's not fit
for them and now these more recent
episodes are showing a salad fingers's
approach to his own kids he's loving
compassionate he's trying his hardest to
break the cycle of neglect even if it
figuratively and literally consumes him
except rarely do things end happily in
the world as Salad Fingers the true
tragedy of all of this despite his
efforts it doesn't work boy fingers is
still trapped in this cycl of
self-hatred still consumed by the sins
of his past why do I say this well not
only does he literally kill his own
parent that looks identical to him that
right there that's a pretty big red flag
but more importantly it all comes down
to this rock yeah I'm serious you see
this rock it isn't just any rock it has
a name this is
B and he's the weapon that boy fingers
uses to strike Salad Fingers in the head
before boiling him in the stew
Bartholomew here he was the murder
weapon used to end salad fingers's life
this is important because in the
previous episode Postman Salad Fingers
says this Bartholomew deise my oldest
Chum hopefully the legal troubles are
behind you Bartholomew is facing legal
troubles almost as if he killed someone
as if he was the person who killed the
previous Salad Fingers now you might
think that this is just an unrelated
moment but we have proof that the murder
and the legal troubles are one and the
same see when Postman was first uploaded
people were curious about what these
legal troubles were enough so that one
person named Wilkinson X went so far as
to ask David fth if they were going to
get a backstory on them and David fth
confirmed that they would find out more
in the next episode cut to harvest and
the violent murder of Salad Fingers this
proves that the salad fingers were
following in Postman is actually boy
fingers all grown up they're happening
in reverse order which means that this
new boy fingers he's still confronting
the Dark Truth of his father's
conception as Hubert cumberdale he's
still having to deal with the
inappropriate relationship that his
grandfather Jeremy fiser had with a much
younger woman and he's still grappling
with the Fallout of what all of this did
to Hubert's family life growing up this
is all about the Ripple effects of
trauma and how it tends to carry through
generation after generation maybe if boy
fingers had listened before boiling his
dad alive then yeah maybe this could
have been avoided but at least for now
there doesn't seem to be any sort of
Escape for salad fingers from this
vicious cycle what he needs here is to
process the pain of his past in order to
not pass it along to the Next Generation
in order for Salad Fingers to truly grow
to move on he has to bury the puppet of
his past but hey that's just a theory a
film Theory and
[Music]
cut